one of my favorite guests to talk ball
Brian Wynn worst senior reporter of the
Association on ESPN how are you Brian
hello rich you great column great story
today about just laying it all bare so
I'd love you to bring it to the people
right here on my program how realistic
is what needs to happen I guess for
Anthony Davis to join the Lakers Brian
well it's not I think what needs to
happen rich is he'd have to come out and
say trade me to the Lakers and I just
don't know first off I spent some time
with them I don't think that's what he
where he is I really do think he's
focused on the pelicans and he has never
given indication anything but you know
but that and also the pelicans have no
interest in trading him right now
they're looking to supplement and trying
to make trades a supplement him that
said you just talked about LeBron being
very very aware of everything he does
being blown up he knew exactly what he
was doing when he gave this quote and I
want to just give a little bit of
context this is to my colleague Dave
McMenamin Scalia is known and is a very
good relationship with he gave this
quote on the record away from a media
scrum he knew exactly what he was doing
was specially the fact that the pelicans
are going to be in LA on Friday to play
the Lakers and the reason this is so
interesting there's this very strange
really obscure rule and that rule is
that the Celtics cannot trade for
Anthony Davis this season and it's it's
hard to explain and I apologize for its
complexity but you can't have what is
known in the NBA as two designated
players you can't trade for two
designated players you become a
designated player based on the type of
contract you sign
Kyrie Irving is a designated player
Anthony Davis is a designated player
they have diary they cannot trade for
Anthony Davis of course you could trade
Kyrie for Anthony Davis but that would
defeat the purpose of team building so
we're not going to go there so if the
Celtics and the reason that's relevant
is that in my mind rich the Celtics have
the best package they can offer if Davis
becomes available in you know next
summer if he does not sign a contract
extension and forces the pelicans hands
just like Kawhi Leonard forces for his
hand when he wouldn't sign a contract
extension so if you're
the Lakers your best-case scenario I
believe is to try to get Anthony Davis
before this trade deadline before you
have to compete with the Celtics and
other teams and potentially teams to win
the top three of the draft and whatnot
over the summer and so I think that is
all in the bronze eyes he is aware of
all of that he's definitely aware of it
because he's got the same age in his
Anthony Davis and I just think he wanted
to get the conversation started two
months away from the trade deadline
Bryant we marched here on the Rich Eisen
show ok so then now now let's get to the
why so LeBron has taken stock of what's
in Los Angeles right now and is pegged
Anthony Davis as well as taking stock as
to who others on the landscape might be
and whether their willingness to join
has already been sussed out and he
pegged Anthony Davis Ryan yeah I think
rich I think if you look at the top
three agents me one of the reasons why
you'd want to play with LeBron is to
have the opportunity to compete and win
four championships because there's a lot
of challenges and downsides that come
with them the upside is if you play with
him he will have you compete but if you
look at the top three agents next summer
these guys already have championships
Kawhi Leonard and the and Finals MVP
Kevin Durant two titles and Counting
klay Thompson has a title it's good I
think it's going to be a hard road to
hoe the Lakers in this free agent market
I think they're better chance is to try
to figure out a way to trade for
somebody who wants to be in LA how
that's complicated it's not easy when
you train somebody you don't get to
control the four corners I think
ultimately LA is such a draw and LeBron
is a draw and eventually they'll get
somebody I don't think I'm worried about
that if I'm LeBron but let's point out
in 10 days LeBron turns 34 you know he
doesn't want to do this for three years
and this is one of the things he's he's
talked about this I mean if you look at
this roster there's two types of players
on this roster which there's veterans
who are all in one-year contracts who
all could be gone next year to clear cap
space or whatever and there's young guys
who are either auditioning to play with
LeBron long term
with him and right now Brandon Ingram
does not or are you just being you know
fattened up to be traded for a player
like you uppity Dave I don't think
there's a you know he talked about how
good the chemistry is but I don't think
he's got a particular affinity for
almost anyone on the roster he knows
they can all be sent out
except maybe Lonzo ball he really seems
to be connected with Lonzo ball but if
if the pelicans called Montford Anthony
Davis and Y Alonzo ball LeBron would say
have a nice career we'll see it Brian
one horse here on the Rich Eisen show I
mean it it is amazing I mean over the
weekend he and Lonzo had triple-doubles
in the same game first time that's
happened for the Lakers since magic and
Kareem did it in 1982 so then you see
Kuzma fill it up the heart can fill it
up and then at times they miss open
threes it's just it's a fun watch but
I'm just sitting there wondering who's
that guy that can maybe just from on the
roster have that blossoming season to
become the Robin to the Batman that
doesn't require the Lakers to go out and
bring in that whopping max player free
agent Brian is that is that a
possibility a feasibility I'm wondering
what you are hearing and thinking
yourself he's probably that there right
now I mean I don't want to put a ceiling
on any of these guys I mean we you know
Kuzma and Lonzo kyle Kuzma and Lonzo are
in their second year you certainly
wouldn't look at them and say oh they
are a complete player I mean in theory
they could grow but you I think if you
look at the Lakers they've done a really
nice job of positioning themselves to be
a real factor going forward but if you
look at you know if you say well where
did they make the mistake they had
number two picks to read consecutive
years they took D'Angelo Russell
D'Angelo Russell Brandon Ingram and
Lonzo ball and those were nice players
but they didn't get a Lucca Don Church
they didn't get a Jason Tatum they
didn't get a Donovan Mitchell they
didn't get the Aaron Fox you know you I
guess if the Lakers had drafted the
Aaron Fox if you look at what he's doing
for the Kings like Darren Fox looks like
he's going to be an all-star and
potentially a major impact player Alonso
has very
nice games he's up he's a really nice
guy to have on your team but you don't
look at him and say boy he's the number
two on a championship team at least not
right now I don't see that I don't think
that's a reactionary thing to say if
they've been able to hit on one of those
number two picks and I mean like Willie
hit a franchise cornerstone piece their
outlook would be different but for
various reasons and I'm not saying I
could've done better they weren't able
to do that at three bites at the Apple
so then last one for you on this subject
before we move on on other Association
topics Brian what is LeBron hoping to
achieve by pulling McMenamin over and
giving him that quote knowing that it
would be run on all the platforms of the
worldwide leader I mean what is he
hoping to do just get-get Davis's
attention which obviously he could do
through his agent I mean what what is he
shaking the tree in Los Angeles I mean
cuz he also mentioned he'd love to give
Carmelo a whirl here I mean what do you
think LeBron is hoping to achieve you it
made me smile because this is how LeBron
rolls I mean he is gonna deliver you
twenty seven seven and seven every night
he's gonna fill up your building he's
gonna make you irrelevant he's gonna
make you tens of millions of dollars a
year in revenue he's gonna add a couple
hundred million dollars to your value of
your franchise I mean and he's gonna
play passive-aggressive GM this is what
he does he's done it for a long time now
this is what he does and you know I just
you know LeBron is probably the most
aware person I've ever met repair his
awareness of people on the court his
awareness of people in the room his
awareness of the power of his voice he
is extraordinarily aware that if the
Lakers could get Alonzo ball doing it
before this trade deadline would be the
best way to do it and he knows that
Anthony I'm sorry not Lonzo ball Emily
Davis and he knows that you know if he
talks about it it begins the
conversation the conversation has begun
okay so what else
[Laughter]
it's amazing how an eight 18 and 13 team
takes up so much oxygen when the
Warriors have already lost 10 games but
they seem to have righted the ship I
mean the question is is who from the
east could actually emerge and
and become a threat so let me try this
when are the Nuggets for real Brian well
you know they're really banged up right
now rich they're missing like three of
their best players but they're still
winning you know they're still hanging
in there and that what's so amazing
about the Nuggets is they were one of
the worst defensive teams last year like
hideous terrible awful bottom three
there will be some nights where like you
would make you sick if you were Nuggets
tan to watch now in one year and they've
made a couple of adjustments for their
team but not dramatically they've
essentially got the same core team
they're in the top five
like that is unheard of it's so unheard
of that I question whether it can last
so if you say you're asking me to there
for real they have already so blown away
my expectations like even they came into
the season and I thought they were I
thought they were being pretty fair they
were like we just want to be an average
defensive team if we can be an average
defensive team we can win 50 games and
make the playoffs and by the way I
agreed but now they're an elite
defensive team so if they hold that up
and their players get healthy they're a
real problem because they are as good
offensively as the Warriors maybe not
their top and maybe not on a night when
when you know Steph's and Duran are both
going they're both 440 okay maybe no one
in history can match that but on an
average night there is good offensively
as the warrior so they're interested but
I'd say is remarkable is that as we sit
here today rich there are five teams
that made the playoffs in the West last
year that are currently out of the
playoffs and a couple of things that we
thought might have a chance to be the
real contenders for the Warriors the
Jazz and the Rockets all the Rockets are
rallying you know they're there I mean
we've just never seen that kind of
turnover not only that we've got the
Celtics and the and the 76ers in the
East neither of them are in the top
three right now ya know what we expected
for this season is not playing out but
you know typically in the NBA over the
long haul the best teams rise to the top
but I still think that's probably gonna
happen but I I don't feel sure about it
all right so your best guess on the team
that the Warriors and Steve curve heart
of hearts quiet moment pull him aside
and say we're concerned about this team
welcome and by the way by the way Brian
all of it by the way Brian you can
include the answer being the Warriors
themselves well the Warriors have this
big giant x-factor out there that I have
no idea and literally a giant guy in
DeMarcus Cousins I really just don't
know how that's gonna go I mean there's
a there's a scenario out there where
DeMarcus Cousins could could make them
virtually unbeatable there's other
scenarios where he's not going to be
himself coming off of the worst injury
you can suffer in the NBA and that maybe
he'll play too impactful quarters and
the entire postseason and I think
there's a wide spectrum too you know so
without knowing what he's gonna do and
rich Nate they took a gamble with them
because they are very thin team you know
some of their some of their veteran
bench players either retired or moved
elsewhere and they invested almost all
their free agency money and bringing in
a guy who was locked in a play for most
of the season and instead of going out
and adding to their depth so they've
like been relying on guys who were
d-league players you know they've called
up guys in the d-league and played them
like 15 minutes that is not what you
typically have them from a championship
team so they need him to play well and
so they are a little bit softer at the
back end of their or their lineup than
they've been in the last five years that
said the front end of their lineup is
like loaded loaded loaded so I'm not
really losing sleep over that but the
Raptors are an interesting team they've
already beat the Warriors twice which I
know doesn't matter in the grand scheme
but the Raptors have two guys now who
have championship level experience in
Kauai and Danny Green and Danny Green
played a big role against the Warriors
and they've got this young guy tossed
off Viacom who doesn't carry the baggage
of all those failures in the playoffs I
think the Raptors are a different level
team and they have done in the past so I
think they can beat the Warriors four
out of seven no but I think that's a
team that is the Bears watching for sure
last one for you Brian Wynn Horst
how did you and/or the rest of the your
colleagues or observers that you've
spoken to take Ian O'Connor's piece
interviewing James Dolan how has that
landed in the NBA community
well boy is that a defiant man I mean I
thought it was a remarkable way he
answered the Anika Browne Sanders
questions especially in the environment
that we're in you know in the same
interview he basically says I I knew
about Harvey Weinstein before all the
rest of everybody and so don't judge me
on my long term friendship with them and
then the same interview says well we
just defended ourselves a little bit
better we had better lawyers we would
have won that lawsuit I was stunned that
he presented himself that way but that's
who he is he's abused a defiant guy I
think if you're a Knicks fan
you were happy to hear that he intends
to stay out of basketball that he didn't
have any input on the coaching hire when
they hired David says Dale that he seems
to like his executive because the more
he has gotten involved historically the
more difficult it has become but I
wouldn't have read that and said boy I
changed my viewpoint of how Jim Dolan is
and and we're at a point where the
Knicks are gonna have a bite at this
Apple they have a chance to get somebody
in free agency they have a chance to
maybe get an impact player in the draft
and that get poisonous back there is a
moment coming here where the Knicks
could all could have a rebound but I
didn't read that and think that their
chance is improved Brian I really love
our chats and your work thanks for
calling in brother I already look
forward to the next time thanks have a
good you too that's Brian Wynn worst a
twin worst ESPN the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience